what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series where we do reactions in
good faith um and don't take people out
of context and you know
um really you're trying to fight the
fake news TMZ reaction channels that
stand for nothing believe nothing and
really are just the critics of YouTube
um anyways uh pull the clip uh King this
uh Destiny was on fresh and fit all
right and it says oh sneako girlfriend
teaches Destiny how to keep frame in a
relationship okay can I ask one question
that I'll give you all the four can we
go around the table how many girls have
been in a decently long-term
relationship so we'll say six months
plus that have enjoyed having a guy like
with your head like this where you're
like oh yeah like he's not responding
for a week bro I'm not gonna admit that
bro okay yeah and see that's that's
where we get this disconnect right
sneako saying well the women are saying
they don't like that and Myron is saying
well this is what is true women do like
games now this is really tough for the
more blue pill dudes you know blue pill
dudes to understand
um and I'm not saying I'm proud of this
but when I look at the results I mean I
had this stuff on on the show right I
would say oh do you guys like what men
that play games they would say no but
then I started asking when I would say
um you know I think women like being
cheated on I got so much Flack for this
opinion and the reason I I think this is
because I look at what women do and I
would ask girl after girl after girl and
guys guys these were not just ratchet
they were not just these were just
normal a lot of the girls that come on
my show probably the majority King why
don't you agree the majority are just
normal chicks like they're not they act
like we bring on these crazy women on
purpose it's like some are crazy but a
lot are normal right yeah very normal
very normal like like I think if you
look at a dating app or like if you walk
down the street really it's gonna
represent it but but okay so so these
girls
um I would ask them have you ever been
cheated on they would say no or they
would say yes right and then they would
say I would say okay when you found out
he was cheating did you leave or did you
stay and what do you think the most
common answer has been well I stayed
they might have broke up with him later
they stayed so to me it's and a lot of
times the girls would leave when he
stopped cheating so again like they
could say oh I hate cheaters but we pick
them we all know that the majority of
men can't cheat so if we're picking a
guy that cheats is there a part of us
that likes the drama okay
I've talked to a lot of women I've never
heard somebody say yeah I'm like my
boyfriend he didn't text me back for
like three days and that was just like
the best thing
most women are addicted to emotions so
it's a stimulant because most women are
addicted to emotions everybody's
addiction
it's a stimulant because you don't get
complacent in it if you're constantly
wondering like damn does this mean okay
that's fine but if you live your life
that keeps you literally focused on one
person instead of getting attention from
other people and she'll lose interest
she's not gonna stay with you number one
and number two the only types of girl
that will maintain interest are the
girls are gonna show up at 6am slash
your tires
to respect you
should listen like he always steamrolls
and like talks over people like like let
her she's trying to explain a point let
her talk wait you think she's gonna
respect that that's the same time comes
in what is the phrase I can't be around
you for more than four days in a row
without like being this is dominance and
knowing to put you in your place because
what is your place in a separate house
if you show up to his [__] house
unannounced he's gonna be like yo this
is done that's where frame comes in she
understands [__] that you hate her no
did you hear how he took that so she's
saying she like so if the girl knows
that okay if I step out of line he's
done there's no if answer but it's when
a girl acts crazy and a guy accepts that
and there's no consequence that she's
gonna keep acting crazy but she's
talking about he has to keep her in his
frame and then he's saying now he's
saying that she hates him what or he
hates her what I I just think Destiny is
a very intelligent guy but he lacks a
lot of social intelligence because a lot
of things he says just seems like either
he has been so lucky with women maybe
because he has money or whatever I I
don't know it just seems like he just
has this very
um weird view on life where only his
anecdotal experiences should be the
right thing it's like bro if a woman is
telling you how they see um
relationships first of all you're not
even a woman second of all we all know
the kind of women you you probably go
for so we can't even take your own
perspective as gospel so it's like
there's a lot of weird Dynamics going on
here but I mean yeah well because what
did it kind of support what she's saying
the like games or whatever if that's
like is that imagine an open
relationship that's gotta come with all
sorts uh you know I don't know
this is like the most adversarial
relations I've ever heard in my life
what these relationships are adversarial
are you serious right now yeah are you
serious right now is he serious right
now if you respect somebody it doesn't
matter how crazy you get you get in your
emotions you aren't gonna just pull up
up to their [__] house were
unannounced without their permission
because you're gonna know he's gonna
he's not gonna tolerate that that's what
frame is knowing that he's the leader
he's in charge you don't go over there
unless he announced like he tells you to
come I think in a relationship where two
people love each other I think showing
up unannounced could be like a fun
surprise sometimes but I guess you guys
are talking about a woman that's the
main that's the serenading The Man shows
up on the woman unannounced it's the
woman should never show up on the main
unannounced okay yeah
crazy and I would say relationships I
mean if you look at like what men want
versus what women want it's inherently
adversarial and the reason why is
because men are looking for sex women
are looking for resources time and
attention I like her she should have a
channel I like her it's a dance between
the two genders to get the other
commodity from the other without giving
up there so for example that's not even
true though really really hold on let me
explain hold on before you do
explanation this is the easiest thing in
the world
he sounds like a little kid that was
bullied like on the playground like
always trying to be the one that has the
smartest responses the like bro that's
not what the conversation is about the
conversation is not about being the
person to deliver the message that
everyone hears it's about getting the
right message no and that's what it was
when um he was here like I just felt
like I couldn't talk to him because he
was just like
and it's it's like I hate having
conversations with people that don't go
into things in good faith because even
if you're correct and you don't let the
other person speak then it just becomes
it's no longer a conversation it's more
like you think you're better than the
other person and whatever you say is
Gospel yeah well even when he was here I
was talking about how you shouldn't get
divorced over chores and and then he
just starts going personal he's like you
sound like a kid right now have you ever
been in a serious relation like like
this this this this and this and then
I'm like okay well what does it have to
do with what I said what does it have to
do with uh because it's weird though
because it's like the YouTubers that
have been on YouTube for so long it's so
weird the way they talk okay do you do
you notice it like they come in and
you'll ask them like is the sky blue and
then they'll be like you know what the
sky is blue but and like if if their
point is let's just say like a woman's
issue but women are discriminated
against every single day women like
they'll have like a monologue and it's
so weird in normal conversations because
you'll be like you'll ask them like a
general question and they'll just
oh my gosh if you go and you find an
insult okay an actual in cell all right
what is the thing they're looking for
most in life it's not sad
the love and warmth and compassion of
being a relationship right that's the
people that's what guys and the sections
but not just sex but the idea that
somebody loves them and accessible does
he know any insults do you you know any
insults I don't know any except
except you know
um never mind have sex with them that's
why you can't tell an inso yo just go
buy a prostitute and go [__] her for a
night or that's why you can't tell any
man like if you make enough money just
different hooker every night you want
something that loves and accepts you
that's part of being a relationship
here's the thing you didn't refuse what
I was trying to say was the the two
genders are in our adversarial in
general and the reason why is because
both parties want something from the
other without necessarily giving up
their situation I'll give you if you've
got courts a girl right she wants time
attention and resources from that man
before she gives him sex right and uh I
guess uh how do you say this an
indicator of a man having good game is
being able to not get all that up while
simultaneously getting sex that's what
the parameter that guys use to establish
if a guy has a good game so what I'm
saying is that the two genders once want
the commodity that the other one has
without giving up their commodity so
it's inherently adversarial now I get
what you're saying oh well you're in a
relationship Etc you still have to play
the game when you're with your wife I
think I think the goal is that if you're
with a person you enjoy giving them the
time the attention of the resources
because it makes both of you happy when
you give it to them in an abundant
fashion they don't respect it anymore
and here's the thing dude I wish it
wasn't like that but women don't respect
you when they have left I think when
you're selecting for crazy women like
this maybe but for most women I think
they want you to want to spend time and
attention and resources
to get the best out of your girl where
she's they say they want it but their
actions always and that story and that's
what the red pill is is it's saying this
is what women say but it's not what we
do
and and the idea I mean if even if we do
this with I don't know steak right like
steak it's more of like a fancy food
like I don't know what what's the best
part of a steak I don't know like the
fancy like a fit 50 I don't know 100
T-Bones yeah T-bone steak if steak might
be like a pleasant thing that you get
every now and then but if you eat it
every single day you're not gonna value
it as much so if someone's giving you
all of their time their attention and
their resources why would you value it
as much I've heard so many guys tell me
that they can't treat a girl too well
otherwise she takes advantage of them
and these are normal women guys it's not
like oh this is the Miami like it's like
how many pop-up shows do we have to do
in different countries or in different
parts of the world so I do a pop-up show
in London right I do a live show
whatever fresh and fit do a live show in
Miami whatever podcast does a live show
um with women in the studio in
California
um Rolo does a show in Vegas it's like
like four different shows with four
different recruiting systems and four
different parts of the world coming to
the same conclusion and especially
London do you know how diverse London is
and it's not like we're pre-selecting
for anything other than young and
attractive that's it that that's anyway
we're not even too picky about that
let's just be honest here
um if we're all coming to the same
conclusions like this doesn't count for
anything nothing all right super loyal
to you she's not doing anything else on
the side she only loves in Mars respects
you there's no function and she stays
loyal to you you must have to leverage
as the man God that you if you leave her
her life is gonna suck significantly
more so what's she gonna do she's gonna
be what I'm telling you know operate the
best when they're stepping on eggshells
not trying to get you mad or get broken
up with I think that's been three days a
week away from your woman she's gonna be
sucking another dick in like two months
three days a week what
wait wait wait wait wait wait I'm just
thinking of my parents I'm like and I
know they always make fun of me because
I have I have family experience right
it's like doesn't count I guess my dad
would go away for a while and my parents
didn't cheat on each other and I'm like
so if you have no self-control that if
you don't see a man you have to see him
like you can't go three days without
seeing it why you're otherwise then
you're gonna like what what type of
women are you speaking to that's my
question it's crazy because everything
is just flipped in the Western World
when I was growing up my dad had to live
in a different state because of work and
I could count how many times in a year
we used to see him but he didn't change
the dynamic of the house it didn't
change who was your mom didn't have
boyfriends your mom didn't no other men
coming around like and that's the thing
because I out of all out of all my
siblings I think I'm the one that I
spent the most time with my mom because
all my siblings okay maybe me and my
younger brother but my two sisters went
off to boarding school I was with my mom
with actually since that was born almost
up until I went to UNI almost every
single day so like when it's just crazy
when I see women here say stuff like
it's all like what Destiny is saying
that
um you you need to be with your woman
every single day and bro I think the
woman will get tired of you a lot of
diminishing return anyways like that's
true we don't like men with a ton of
free time to be honest like it just kind
of turns we don't want to just like
signals if he's always if you're always
seeing him then that is every time you
see him that is him not being out there
getting money it's like a signal if you
so imagine if you're seeing him every
single day and he's at home every single
day even if he might be making money
online it doesn't change the signal your
brain is going to be receiving yeah
because your brain doesn't know the
difference it's just like when people
say negative stuff or stuff like that
they think that your brain cannot
differentiate like the words you're
saying it can only differentiate the
feelings or the signal it receives so
it's like
yeah if you guys want to see the full
clip I'm in contact go to fresh and fits
Channel
um you know because here we do good
faith reactions
um where we do believe in something and
we do stand for something unlike these
reaction channels that stand for nothing
believe nothing you know like we stand
for we believe in masculinity and
femininity we believe in polarity in
relationships and we believe
um that women really aren't happy with
feminine men
um and we also believe that you should
be able to go three days without seeing
a guy and not suck another you know I
think I think that I call me
old-fashioned you know what I mean but
let me know what you guys think in the
comments like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell I'll talk to you next
time